fundamentally there's a lot at stake
because they're trying to answer
something really big how the universe
begin did time begin with the Big Bang
and after the universe began it then
went through a really rapid period of
expansion called inflation
that's one possibility another
possibility is the universe didn't begin
with the big day but rather has gone
through a cycle of collapse and then re
expansion that second models called the
aquatic universe those are two very
different theories how the universe
began two very different theories of
universes origin and what we're going
after is to try to distinguish between
those two theories
[Music]
and what's exciting about doing
experiment like this we're gonna do a
measurement we will ideally show that
one of these theories is wrong if the
inflationary model is correct then it
predicts it should produce gravitational
waves that'd be a great triumph for the
inflationary theory and more importantly
would mean we'd have to abandon any
alternative theory that doesn't predict
gravitational waves
I see the Simon's Observatory as the
ultimate time machine being able to look
back to when not only the light predated
light but gravity and when the universe
itself when gravity potentially was
still in a quantum state when all the
matter and energy universe were in this
ultra compactified configuration or not
and if we do see that how exciting would
that be but even if we don't see that
what does it tell us about these other
laws
[Music]
we'll be able to either detect quantum
gravitational waves from the Big Bang's
inflationary epoch which would be
incredible an incredible feat or we
could potentially have better
understanding that perhaps the universe
didn't originate in an inflationary
expansion but was actually there was a
universe before ours and just as we want
to know our universes origin story now
there'd be an answer to that question of
what happened before our universe
so for the last 50 years the prevalent
idea has been to assume that the
universe began with a bang there was
nothing and then something if you begin
with that idea though you immediately
run into trouble
this sudden beginning due to the effects
of quantum physics produces a universe
in which the distribution of matter and
energy is extremely non-uniform it's
actually not what we see we observe a
universe which on the large is extremely
uniform and which seems to be flat the
question is why well if you assume the
universe began with a bang the only way
that has been proposed to explain how it
would be smooth and flat is this idea of
inflation it turns out that you begin to
expand the universe at this accelerating
rate quantum physics takes over and
totally distorts what happens next
instead of producing everywhere a
universe that looks like us it actually
produces a patchy universe with an
infinite number of patches which have
different properties and this is what's
called the multiverse this multiverse
idea kills all the advantages of the
theory because instead of explaining why
the universe is as the way it is it
actually produces an infinitude of
possibilities suppose the bang were
instead of bounce suppose space and time
existed before this bang and instead of
the universe springing from nothing
there was actually a long slow period of
gradual contraction slow enough for the
universe to interact with itself smooth
out the distribution of matter radiation
bounce and then produced an expanding
universe like with the properties we
observe today with astronomy we have to
wait for these things to come to us I
have to use what comes to me it's like
being on the ocean and getting driftwood
and trying to learn about where was this
forest where this piece of wood came
from an ultimate message in a bottle and
with this telescope we look back in time
not only to when there was light but to
when there was gravity
and when the universe existed so the
time that gravity existed predates the
time that the CMB was formed so we can
actually look back farther in time and
in space using waves of gravity so if
these waves of gravity are seen it would
be the earliest possible way to look
back into time along the way we're gonna
find out so much else about the universe
in addition to this gravitational
lensing gravitational waves the presence
of dark energy dark matter neutrinos
particles fields energy so all of this
is guaranteed to be accomplished by the
Simons Observatory in many ways the
Simon's Observatory collaboration is a
community of dreamers we're dreaming of
making some advance that will give us a
deeper insight into physics and it's
that common dream that drives us to the
mountaintops it's like building a
cathedral there's lots of pieces and
we're all building our own piece and you
don't want the cathedral cook to
collapse we're pretty close to
converging on a detailed concept of what
this Observatory will look like how will
we build the telescopes what instruments
will we build and how will the pieces
all come together I'm always surprised
when we've finished an array because
they are beautiful and then you put it
in and then you're into the actual
telescope and then you're actually
getting data from it and the data are
incredibly sensitive and usually I have
lost sight of how amazing and good the
device actually is because of being
constantly worried about the small
things about it
often in scientific experiments people
whether they're scientists or the
general public think it's really
important that you detect something and
are disappointed when you don't detect
something but it's important to realize
that not detecting something can often
be very informative maybe even more
informative than detecting something and
this would be an example like that
so not detecting these gravitational
ways or not detecting to be modes which
are the imprint of those cosmic
gravitational waves would be telling us
that the beginning of the universe isn't
what we thought it was a bang in fact it
wasn't it didn't have to be a beginning
at all but there was this bounce instead
[Music]
the question of whether the pursuit of
arcane knowledge is valuable is when I
think about all the time and I usually
come back to thinking that it's similar
to art we're not robots and out of atoms
and you you need to find an experienced
beauty and you need to find beauty and
thinking and in your in your mind and
your understanding of the universe
you're it's true that in this world
there are many more practical problems
to be solved issues about helping
humanity to live life better improving
the climate all those questions have to
be pursued as well but spending a small
amount of effort trying to also satisfy
our curiosity
I think instant makes life more
meaningful for Humanity on this planet
we may not know if inflation took place
because inflation might not have taken
place or maybe it did and it was so
feeble and so weak and we can't
understand why something so feeble and
so we could make such a munificent
beautiful universe but I think that's
kind of a wonderful position to be in
that either alternative is kind of
mind-bending in its own way it's not for
me to say which is more mind-bending
it's privileged to be able to you know
shed light onto either of these two just
fundamental possibilities and I think
that's the most exciting mesmerizing and
question of all you know that which of
these two will be right not which do I
prefer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you